Speaker 1: We have yet another little kernel
of the insanity that has been taking place
behind the scenes with regards to the Donald Trump
bathroom dump of documents. An exclusive Rolling
Stone article now reports that Trump demanded,
quote, my documents back even after his lawyers
told him he would be indicted. This this is just
an unbelievable. It reminds us of the disconnect
from reality that this guy lives in. Look at
this. Last month, Donald Trump's lawyers told him
he was on the cusp of a federal indictment in
the classified documents case. But the former
president still wanted, quote, my documents and
quote my boxes back, asking some of his lawyers
if he could get them from the federal government,
according to a source with direct knowledge of the
matter. And two other people briefed Trump in the
middle of being told you're about to get arrested.
We're saying, can I get my my documents back? I
want to put them back in the bathroom. Maybe he
didn't say that. Going back to the article, it's
one of many such conversations Trump has had over
the past few months. In these conversations, Trump
also claimed it was, quote, illegal that he could
no longer have the documents that were seized.
Those materials, Trump insisted, belonged to
quote me. Trump has also asked if there are any
other possible legal maneuvers or court filings
they could try to accomplish this that they
hadn't thought of yet. You have to remember,
these are not Trump's documents. These are,
in a sense, our documents. They're classified.
Most of us don't actually have a right to see
them, but they are the government's documents,
the government's documents and the article
addresses that. Trump has incorrectly insisted
that the highly classified documents he was
hoarding were, quote, mine, mine. Trump is also
mentioned he'll get the documents back in 2025
because he predicts he'll be pleasant president
again and will then get unfettered access to
the most sensitive secrets of the government.
This is a reminder that this is not a character
that Trump is playing. Trump really is the
bottomless narcissist that he is portrayed to
be by many who know him and many in the media.
Trump really doesn't understand the things
that he is reported not to understand. When
Trump asked about Can we nuke a hurricane? When
Trump asked about Why can't we consider nuking
Europe? Would a flu vaccine work on COVID? When
Trump asked these things and his defenders go,
he didn't ask it, and if he asked it, it was
clearly a joke because he knows everything.
He clearly doesn't. He still believes that these
are his documents, even though they, of course,
are not. And it's a very interesting sort of peek
into the psyche of Trump. And remember, Trump
keeps insisting that there's nothing criminal
related to what he did, these 37 felony counts.
He says it's all governed by the Presidential
Records Act. It is not. It doesn't even seem
he knows what that means, but it is not covered
by the Presidential Records Act. We are talking
here about his actions as a former president.
We are talking about his refusal to give the
documents back. When asked. We are talking about
his direction of lawyers and others to lie and
obfuscate and hide and refuse to give back. We're
talking about all of those different things.
And he keeps insisting it's merely an issue of
the Presidential Records Act. It's not. He doesn't
get it at this point. It's time to just admit he
doesn't get it. He keeps talking about the Clinton
sock drawer tapes as if there's any equivalency
there. Bill Clinton recorded his thoughts while
he was in office on audio tapes. He was granted
permission to keep them after a review to use
them in order to I don't remember if it was to
write a book or what it was. It's not an even
remotely similar situation. Trump is talking about
how of the espionage is. It's never been used like
this. The espionage was used in this way six times
while Trump was president of the United States.
It is not that rare. You can be against how it's
written. You can be against certain provisions or
whatever. It is not unique to Trump. And yet
again completely disconnected from reality.